all right man cheers bro cheers one two
three
yeah you're gonna have to give me a
second
he's from long beach california ladies
and gentlemen put your hands together
for jesus
it's going down season three right here
right now no more of that zoom stuff
we're out in the field let me show you
around it's gonna blow your mind dude oh
man oh my god it's so good oh damn i'm
hungry man good that's hot
[Music]
lamb skulls
this is tacos contolo more tacos more
gas more flavor more calories more
clogged arteries bobby you see this help
wanted sign he thinks we're going to eat
tacos we have some other plants let's go
baby you broke it man oh my god get out
of here can you give me a little bit
more of that back up back up back up we
can't work under these conditions oh yes
you can yeah and you will carlos
straight from mexico city i don't even
want to talk man
i got none other than mark maron now i'm
just eating the spinal cord i don't care
throwing it on the top stevo i'm not a
thrill seeker i'm just an attention
[ __ ]
it's getting it off and scary
you said the best bro i'll give you the
best the world is ending so it's all up
in the air in true mark marion fashion
there it is tacos contolo best show in
america emmy nominated grammy nominated
grammy winner everything
[Music]
[Applause]